the trump campaign is also calling for a
recount in wisconsin
former governor scott walker is casting
doubt about whether that would be
enough to help president trump change
the outcome in that very crucial
battleground state
the republican tweeted yesterday that
joe biden's 20 000 vote lead is quote a
high hurdle
but later tweeted this an error in
reporting could change that
and said that he does support a recount
in wisconsin former governor scott
walker joins us now to discuss
good morning to you governor walker
really good to see you again
good morning great to be with you thanks
for having me on we're glad you're here
let's start with okay 99
of the votes are in in your state there
is a 20
000 difference do you think that he
could actually overcome that
well with millions of votes cast you're
talking about less than one percent
about
point seven percent of the vote is the
difference
between the two candidates and as you
just alluded to it's about 21 000 votes
so right now today if nothing else
changed that is indeed a high hurdle
typically in the past we saw a recount
40 years ago in the presidential
election
it swung about i think the president
gained about 131 votes
nine years ago in a state supreme court
race the swing was about 300 votes
so typically hundreds not thousands of
votes shift in an election
statewide having said that that same
supreme court election years ago
uh in the campus which is still going on
and won't be done until at least 14 days
after the election for the local
entities and then on december 1st
all the state canvas is done at that
point you did have in that supreme court
race
a switch of thousands of votes when they
actually found books that had not been
added to the tally
that's why i said be ready for a recount
but wait till after the canvas
you know the trump campaign is is
claiming irregularities they've
mentioned the word fraud when it comes
to voting in your state what do you have
to say about that when you hear that
what do you think
well there are a number of concerns for
example there are some wards in the city
of milwaukee where there were as many as
200 percent voters voters
that voted 200 percent i should say of
what the previous registered voters are
now to be clear in wisconsin
we have same-day voter registration so
it is clearly possible
uh that you had a surge because many of
those wards not only did democrats focus
you had
unprecedented attention uh by the
president's campaign
in the african-american community in
milwaukee so in some of those wars which
are predominantly african-american
there could have been that kind of an
increase but i think it's worth at least
checking in
to make sure those numbers match up with
people but have you seen any evidence of
fraud governor walker have you seen any
evidence or heard no
but okay all right i have not i'd say no
matter what word you're in if it's 200
of the people who were registered i
think that raises a red flag whether
it's in the city of the suburbs or in a
small town in wisconsin
and that's the sort of thing you find in
the canvas as you check
to make sure the numbers add up because
typically when you have problems out
there it's not corruption it's somebody
made an
error this may not be an error but you
need to at least check into things like
that
so governor walker i want to talk about
the possibility of an error because
under the rules there in wisconsin
the candidate who wants a recount has to
pay for it
that means donations that means real
money from real people
who may not have it to spare so is there
any
record that you've seen of an error in
reporting large enough
to actually change the outcome in
wisconsin
closest you got in 2011 was about 14 000
votes
that shot the 21 000 but it's at least
in that ballpark
and obviously it would depend on what
part of the state it came in in that
case it came in out of the city of
brookfield
which was a very republican leading uh
community in a very republican county
and that did sway the outcome of the
election i don't know that there's an
example of that out there but it's at
least
what i've said is take a breath let's
look at the canvas let's not declare a
winner
until the canvases are complete and once
that's done if there's a big margin out
there then it is indeed difficult to see
to go over that kind of hurdle governor
four years ago
uh president trump flipped wisconsin uh
from blue to red
if uh vice former vice president joe
biden holds on to this twenty thousand
twenty one thousand vote margin
why do you think he will have succeeded
in flipping it back
well i've just said all along this is
gonna be razor thin four years ago the
president
won wisconsin but by less than fifty
percent by
just a [ __ ] really a hair of a
distinction between him and hillary
clinton
it looks like it's going to be about the
same percentage which is why every vote
that's legally cash should be counted
in wisconsin and across the country but
what do you think changed
politically uh governor walker uh from
this uh
from from wisconsin going from a a red
state uh your republican governor there
to
a state with i believe it's a democratic
governor and now potentially joe biden
carrying it
in the presidential race well it's
always been close you had the vote for
governor
uh two years ago was about one percent
difference statewide you have
significant republican majorities in
both houses of the legislature
you have five of the eight members of
congress are
republicans and you have one republican
one democrat state senator
it's a typical battleground state it's
going to be close
every single election and you've had
unprecedented turnout in many parts of
the state of wisconsin
for both joe biden and for donald trump
and i think it's going to continue to be
a battleground state going forward
yeah governor walker actually i think
that's an important corrective there
because there were some polls going in
suggesting there was a wider margin than
turned out to be the case in that little
history lesson there from you i think is
a reminder of why
so thank you very much we appreciate you
getting up with us my pleasure good to
be with you